hey guys i'm abby schart welcome to
abby's kitchen over the past decade
there has been a lot of debate and
controversy over dietary fat in the
wellness community
specifically around saturated fat and
its impact on heart health
but is saturated fat actually bad for
you
does it even raise your cholesterol and
what about plant-based saturated fats
like coconut oil
so in today's video i will be taking a
look at the research to do my
very best to answer these very
controversial questions
but before we jump into my review i want
to start with my general disclaimer that
the information in this video is for
entertainment
and educational purposes only and you
should always seek out the help of a
registered dietitian
or medical professional for your unique
needs
okay so before we get too far into the
research
i do want to start with a quick overview
of the different types of dietary fats
since not all fats are created equal
under the unsaturated fat umbrella
monounsaturated fats have been found to
promote heart health
decrease inflammation and have an
overall
positive effect on blood cholesterol so
it is recommended that we try to include
more foods like avocado olive oil
and nuts and seeds in our diet
polyunsaturated fats which includes both
omega-3 fatty acids
and omega-6 fatty acids are also
associated with
a variety of health benefits for our
heart brain
and joints just to name a few you can
find
omega-3s in fatty fish flaxseed
chia seed hemp seeds walnuts and
soybeans
omega-6s on the other hand can be found
in foods like poultry
eggs whole grains nuts and most commonly
in vegetable oils
like sunflower corn cottonseed and
soybean oil
because omega-6 fats are so abundant in
the diet
most of us are getting more than enough
omega-6
but not enough omega-3 fats i do not
want to go too far down the rabbit hole
on the whole
omega-6 and omega-3 controversy because
that would require a whole other video
to really unpack but simply put
both omega-3s and omega-6
polyunsaturated fats
are essential meaning we need to get
them from
our diet simply put omega-3s are largely
anti-inflammatory
while omega-6s have some
pro-inflammatory properties
but that is not necessarily a completely
bad thing
inflammation is a big bad word that has
been co-opted by wellness culture
but inflammation is actually really
important for some of your bodily
functions
like immunity too much or too chronic
inflammation however
is not so good and can potentially lead
to a wide range of chronic diseases
this is where the recommended omega-6 to
omega-3 ratio
comes from most experts believe that the
ideal ratio of omega-6 to omega-3s is
about four to one or less
with pre-industrialized societies
estimated to be getting closer to
one to one most western societies today
however are getting
20 to 1 or in some cases even higher
so this is why it's really key to us to
make an effort to get
more omega-3s in our diet trans fats on
the other hand
would be classified as a fat that you
would want to limit or avoid
as research consistently shows that they
may increase the risk of heart disease
type 2 diabetes and even death in fact
trans fats may increase the risk of
heart disease more than any other
nutrient or food component
it's therefore not surprising that
health authorities in canada and the
united states
went so far as to ban the use of trans
fats in food production
entirely due to its proven detrimental
effects
most countries in europe asia south
america
the middle east and south africa have
now begun to implement
similar legislation to limit the use of
trans fats
now when it comes to checking food
labels i just want to flag that food
manufacturers
can still say that a food product has 0
grams of trans fats
as long as it has less than 0.5 grams
per serving
but if you manipulate the serving size
to an unreasonable small amount
you can get the trans fats down to under
a half a gram
and then you can say it has zero trans
fats so just to be sure
about whether or not a food product does
have trans fats
i would recommend looking at the
ingredient list and looking out for any
ingredients listed as partially
hydrogenated oils
okay anyways finally is saturated fats
and this is where the controversy lies
saturated fats are commonly found in
animal products like meat
and dairy but it's also found in some
plant foods as well like palm oil
and coconut oil but what is the verdict
on saturated fat
does it increase bad cholesterol and
should we be avoiding it entirely
well before we unpack the controversial
research on saturated fat
i want to quickly talk about the
different types of cholesterol
and their role in the body
so cholesterol has several important
functions like making bilats
for digestion sex hormones like estrogen
and progesterone
and developing vitamin d however
information surrounding the relationship
between cholesterol
food and health has been very confusing
over the past few years
it was first thought that all dietary
cholesterol was bad
and increased blood cholesterol which
ultimately led to the egg boycott of the
21st century since eggs
are high in dietary cholesterol notice
the nuanced
difference here between dietary
cholesterol and
blood cholesterol i'll get way more into
why eggs aren't such a big deal anymore
later on in this video
but first a little overview on types of
cholesterol
and how they impact our heart first is
ldl cholesterol
low density lipoproteins aka ldl
are mainly made up of cholesterol and
lipids with a little bit of protein the
main role of ldl cholesterol is to
transport cholesterol to
body tissues to make things in our body
like hormones
however ldl cholesterol is commonly
known as the bad cholesterol
because when ldl levels are too high
they can build up on the walls of our
arteries
making it difficult for blood to travel
smoothly throughout the body
this can of course result in limited
blood flow blood clots
heart attack or stroke on the other hand
we have
high density lipoprotein aka hdl
cholesterol
and this is known as the good
cholesterol this lipoprotein is
important because it takes the excess
bad ldl cholesterol that hangs out in
our bloodstream
back to the liver where it then is
either reused
or excreted out of the body think of hdl
cholesterol as the custodian that
cleans up the leftover cholesterol
helping to keep the arteries clean
and clear now while not necessarily
cholesterol i also want to quickly touch
on a few other compounds
that also play a role as risk factors
for heart disease
the first is the protein apolipoprotein
b
which is one of the main components of
ldl cholesterol
and is also a strong predictor of heart
disease risk
then there are triglycerides which are a
type of fat that can provide your body
with energy
but research suggests that it is also
associated with heart disease risk
and the third that is often measured is
total cholesterol
which is exactly what it sounds like
this includes both
hdl and ldl and while it is associated
with heart disease
it doesn't really tell us the full story
it's really more of like a first tip
that something might be up okay now
adding to the heart health confusion
is the role of cholesterol particle size
so just like humans come in different
sizes and
shapes so too do cholesterol particles
according to the american heart
association some studies have found that
smaller ldl particles cause more
cardiovascular damage than
larger more volumous ldl particles
this is because larger ldl particles are
unable to penetrate the artery
compared to those smaller particles
which can more easily
bury in and build up which in turn
causes atherosclerosis
because of the ability of small ldl
particles to wedge themselves into the
arteries
it's no surprise that they are
associated with a 40
increase in heart disease risk it has
been thought that this
may also explain why some people
diagnosed with heart disease
may not have ldl cholesterol levels that
are particularly high
but they may have a lot of smaller ldl
particles putting them at risk
having said that one study suggested
that once
other risk factors were controlled for
ldl particle size was
not an independent predictor of heart
disease risk
we do need a lot more larger scale
studies to tease us
out but why do some people for example
have more small or more large ldl
particles in their blood
we don't really know but some research
suggests that particle size may be
determined by
genetic and environmental factors like
diet
exercise medication age and hormones
again we need a lot more research to
determine how we can limit the number of
small
ldl particles in favor of larger ldl
particles if they even play a role in
heart disease
but one older study did suggest that
there may be an
inverse relationship between
triglyceride levels
and ldl particle size meaning the higher
your blood triglycerides
the more small ldl particles in your
blood
and the lower triglyceride level is
associated with larger ldl particles
with this in mind in order to reduce the
number of small ldl particles
it may be helpful to focus on
evidence-based ways
of lowering your overall triglyceride
levels so doing things like eating more
fiber
exercising regularly avoiding trans fats
eating more sources of omega-3 fats like
fatty fish
limiting alcohol consumption etc all of
which i'm going to discuss
a lot more at the end of this video okay
so what the heck is the average person
supposed to worry about
when it comes to blood cholesterol well
much the same as the omega-6
to omega-3 ratio that we talked about
the most important thing when it comes
to cholesterol
is having a healthy balance between ldl
and hdl cholesterol while ldl
cholesterol
does have important functions in the
body it's important that we have enough
hdl cholesterol
in the blood to counteract some of the
negative effects of
excess ldl meaning if ldl is taking
cholesterol through the body
but there isn't enough hdl to help
remove any excess
ldl cholesterol is more likely to build
up in the arteries
and cause negative health impacts so
think of them as actually working
together as a team
with hdl being the one in charge
if ldl starts taking over and hdl cannot
keep up with the workload
total chaos ensues however if
hdl takes control of the situation and
make sure
ldl is bringing the right amount of
cholesterol to our tissues
then we have another jolly day in the
office
so to summarize and simplify if i can
because i know it's complex
the major risk factors for heart disease
that we want to
try to modulate and the goals that we
want to aim for are
high hdl cholesterol low ldl cholesterol
low apolipoprotein b low triglycerides
and low total cholesterol so with all
this talk about cholesterol
what about the cholesterol in foods like
eggs or shrimp
is it safe to eat foods that are high in
cholesterol or will this impact
my cholesterol levels like i briefly
mentioned earlier
it had long been thought that dietary
cholesterol from foods like eggs
would have a negative impact on bad ldl
cholesterol
however research then started to show
that the dietary cholesterol in eggs
wasn't the same as the blood cholesterol
being measured in the lab
in fact some research pointed out that
changes in dietary cholesterol intake
had a very limited effect on a person's
total blood cholesterol levels
to put it into perspective reducing
dietary cholesterol by 200 milligrams a
day
correlated to a reduction in ldl
cholesterol of a pathetic
0.11 millimoles per liter
meanwhile most individuals with high
cholesterol would require reduction in
ldl of over
15 times that amount the lack of impact
of dietary cholesterol from eggs on
blood cholesterol
was echoed in a recent 2020
meta-analysis
which concluded that moderate
consumption of eggs
of up to one a day is not associated
with heart disease
with all that said there's no need to
specifically limit the amount of dietary
cholesterol
consumption for the average healthy
adult with normal cholesterol levels
however for individuals with high blood
cholesterol levels
diabetes heart disease or other chronic
diseases
the recommendation is to limit the
amount of dietary cholesterol
to around 200 to 300 milligrams a day
which is equivalent to about
one to two eggs per day depending on
their size
okay so if cholesterol from foods
doesn't necessarily
raise blood cholesterol then it must be
from saturated fat
right like i said earlier research on
the impact of saturated fat and
cholesterol and overall heart health
is controversial stuff despite the
growing amount of research
on saturated fat and the influx of
systematic reviews
health professionals have yet to really
come to a consensus
as to whether or not saturated fat has
any major impact on our health
the reality is especially if you look
back into the early metabolic ward
studies of the 80s and the 90s
there are plenty of studies pointing the
finger at saturated fat as raising bad
ldl cholesterol and a lipoprotein b
as well as increasing the ldl to hdl
ratio
all of which are really important
negative risk factors
that we already discussed for heart
disease as a result
most dietary guidelines including the
recently revised canada's food guide
continue to recommend limiting saturated
fat consumption
to no more than 10 percent of your daily
calories
dietary recommendations to limit or
avoid saturated fats
largely stem from dr ancel key's diet
heart
hypothesis from the 1950s so dr
key's hypothesis was the first to
suggest that
fat should be avoided in the diet
because it leads to heart disease
he then went on to spearhead the seven
countries study of 1958
which was an epidemiological
longitudinal study
meaning it measured the risk of heart
disease in a large population
over a long period of time while the
seven countries studies
did find an association between
saturated fat and heart disease
it has been heavily criticized even to
this day
critics have pointed out that keys
cherry-picked data from countries based
on desired outcomes
and excluded countries like france for
example which have higher intakes of
saturated fat
the study also didn't distinguish
between saturated fat and trans fats
and it also didn't consider sugar as a
potential contributor
there have since been a lot of other
better studies that have found an
association between saturated fat intake
and heart disease including but not
limited to the ireland boston heart
study
the honolulu heart program and the
atherosclerosis
risk of community study while these
studies all conclude that saturated fat
intake
is associated with increased risk of
coronary heart disease
they also found that low intakes of
polyunsaturated fats
and high fiber complex carbohydrates
were also associated with increased
risk similarly a recent 2020
meta-analysis
concluded that reducing saturated fat
intakes lowered the risk of
cardiovascular disease by 21
but this reduction had little effect on
the risk of dying
the review likewise suggests that
replacing saturated fats with
polyunsaturated fats and healthy carbs
may also be beneficial
there have also been other recent
meta-analysis that add
tons of confusion the 2014 publication
in the annals of internal medicine found
that there was no association between
saturated fat and heart disease but this
study was
heavily critiqued for its poor research
methods there was also more recent 2015
canadian meta-analysis and systematic
review of 12 prospective cohort studies
where the authors similarly concluded
that saturated fat
does not appear to be significantly
related to coronary heart disease
cardiovascular disease stroke type 2
diabetes
or all-cause mortality what they found
was that replacing saturated fats with
carbohydrates
had no beneficial impact but replacing
saturated fats with monounsaturated fats
and polyunsaturated fats did have a
positive
impact on cholesterol levels in fact it
was found that including
more unsaturated fats may reduce the
risk of heart disease by about 30
percent
and lower bad ldl cholesterol now it's
important to note that the authors
didn't specify whether the type of
carbohydrates used were high fiber carbs
or refined carbs which would be a really
important distinction
as high fiber low gi carbs have been
shown to have a positive
impact on cholesterol and other
biomarkers of disease
for example research i've already cited
has found that lower glycemic index
carbs
are a healthy alternative to saturated
fats there was also a large 2010
prospective cohort study
of over 50 000 danish women and men
which found that replacing saturated
fatty acids with
lower glycemic index higher fiber
carbohydrates
was associated with a lower risk of
heart disease
whereas replacing saturated fats with
higher glycemic index carbs
was associated with a higher risk so it
is really
all about the little details another
2016 systematic review and meta-analysis
with over 600 000 participants
specifically looked at butter
consumption
which as we know is high in saturated
fats here it was found that there was a
small to neutral effect of consuming
butter on heart disease
type 2 diabetes and all-cause mortality
however as i mentioned earlier there are
other studies that have shown that
saturated fats like butter
does increase ldl cholesterol this may
mean
that while there may be no clear
indications that butter is the main
or sole contributor to these heart
diseases
it can impact markers of heart disease
like cholesterol
now while the study found little to no
effect from eating better
it also mentioned that including more
unsaturated fats
have positive health benefits so does
that mean you should go to town and eat
more butter probably not i mean
too much of anything isn't necessarily
good for you and eating
more saturated fat which has either a
negative
or potentially a neutral effect
depending on which study you read
should not really be the goal rather
what it says to me is according to the
research
it may mean that enjoying a little
butter on your mashed potatoes
may not have the overwhelming negative
effect on heart health
that we once believed so i know i know
who to believe on all this right
nutrition research is notoriously
rife with confounders and
inconsistencies and of course
the evidence on saturated fat is no
different
but to me it comes down to a really
important
question what has a greater impact on
heart disease
high intakes of saturated fats or low
intakes of polyunsaturated fats and
complex carbohydrates
by looking at the body of evidence
considerations around saturated fat and
the risk of heart disease
are really two-fold one saturated fat
in isolation may appear to play a role
in heart disease by increasing heart
disease risk factors
but depending on which research you read
it seems like it may
or may not increase the risk of death
from heart disease itself
shifting the focus to consuming more
unsaturated fats
seems to have a more clear beneficial
effect in the literature
with that said we should be less
concerned with the total saturated fat
intake
and more concerned with emphasizing
greater intakes
of unsaturated fats specifically
polyunsaturated fats
like omega-3s and two replacing
saturated fats with high fiber
carbohydrates
but not refined carbohydrates should be
the other goal
as fiber specifically soluble fiber
has demonstrated a clear benefit towards
reducing cholesterol levels
and improving overall heart health now
while the evidence is
mixed as to whether or not saturated fat
actually causes harm
and to what extent what we do know is
that saturated fat also
doesn't seem to provide much benefit to
our heart either
so if we focus instead on adding more of
the clearly beneficial heart-healthy
foods like unsaturated fats
and higher fiber carbs which have shown
a clear benefit
it will naturally kind of edge out any
potential negative health effects of
saturated fat
now with that said what's the deal with
coconut oil
well marketing of coconut oil has
exploded in recent
years which can of course give people
the impression
that this is really really good for you
but we also know that coconut oil is
high in saturated fat
in fact to compare one tablespoon of
other sources of saturated fat like
butter or ghee or cream
all contain less than 10 grams of
saturated fat per tablespoon
whereas one tablespoon of coconut oil
contains around 12 to 13 grams of
saturated fat
so will coconut oil put you at risk for
heart disease
or is it actually beneficial well
we don't know for sure research on
coconut oil
is admittedly mixed however most quality
research suggests that coconut oil can
in fact raise bad ldl cholesterol
while also raising good hdl cholesterol
interestingly despite being really high
in saturated fats
some research suggests that it may not
raise ldl cholesterol
as much as other saturated fats so
it is possible that the net effect isn't
bad for instance one 2017 randomized
control trial
compared the effects of butter coconut
oil and olive oil
on the cholesterol levels of 96 men and
women
with no previous history of chronic
disease
despite being wildly different in
saturated fat content
there are no differences in the ldl
levels of those fed coconut oil
versus olive oil in contrast butter did
significantly increase ldl cholesterol
compared to coconut oil which was
surprising considering that coconut oil
is actually higher in saturated fat than
butter
again i want to just flag that these are
actually heart disease
risk factors or markers not actual heart
disease
risk but anyways the varying effects of
these two saturated fats on cholesterol
levels
likely has to do with the differences in
their fatty acid profiles
as coconut oil is made up of around 40
percent
lauric acid whereas butter is made up
mainly of palmitic and stearic acids
lauric acid is a unique medium chain
fatty acid
that's digested and metabolized
differently from other kinds of fatty
acids
studies have shown that while lauric
acid does have cholesterol-raising
effects
it is proportionally higher for hdl
cholesterol than ldl cholesterol
another study in women with abdominal
obesity also found that coconut oil
increased hdl cholesterol and even
helped to reduce
waist circumference with all of this in
consideration
despite coconut oil being high in
saturated fat
it may be a better choice compared to
other saturated fats like butter
as it may have a more favorable effect
on cholesterol levels
that said most registered dietitians and
other nutrition professionals
agree that coconut oil should be treated
just like any other food
and enjoyed in moderation while also
being used in rotation with
largely unsaturated fats however if
you're particularly susceptible to high
cholesterol
and unsaturated fat like olive oil may
still be a
better choice what about recommendations
to eat low fat or no fat
or specifically to avoid high fat dairy
the long-standing negative perception of
dietary fat has really resulted in the
preference for a lot of low-fat diets
and low-fat or fat-free products on the
market
however low-fat and fat-free options are
not necessarily healthier
as food manufacturers often have to add
more sodium or more sugar
to compensate for the lack of mouth feel
just use light peanut butter as an
example
if you look at light versus regular
natural peanut butter
you'll see that the light version has
just 10 fewer calories
but it has less protein less healthy fat
more sodium and twice the carbohydrates
so what you're really doing is just
reducing the satiety profile
of peanut butter when you assume that
lower fat is actually better
not to mention it just doesn't taste as
good either as for dairy
we know that the official guidelines
will still tell you to choose
low or fat-free dairy but a lot of the
updated research
doesn't seem to support this idea for
one research
actually suggests that consuming more
high fat dairy
is associated with lower body fat
percentage lower body weight
weight circumference and triglyceride
levels
in the women's health study for example
with almost 20 000 women
they found that higher amounts of
high-fat dairy but not low-fat dairy
was associated with a lower risk of
obesity
research has also looked at its impact
on cardiovascular disease
and type 2 diabetes and in a
comprehensive review of the literature
it was suggested that not only does full
fat dairy
not seem to be associated with heart
disease and type 2 diabetes
but that some full fat dairy like
fermented yogurt
and cheese may actually have a
protective effect
now like most research that looks at an
outcome like weight gain
that doesn't happen overnight these are
cohort studies and
not randomized control trials but there
are a few reasons
why this association may hold true
versus that like with coconut oil and
its lauric acid
there are other components and unique
fatty acids in dairy
that have really unique health
properties so things like conjugated
linoleic acid
butyric acid and palmitoleic acid
higher fat dairy tends to also be more
satiating and satisfying
so you may just not feel the need to eat
as much
or maybe it's what i'll call the weight
watchers effect and that is that
people who eat more higher fat dairy
maybe just tend to diet less often
and have better relationships with food
which we also know
plays a really important role in weight
gain and overall health over time
bottom line i'm not a dairy pusher if
you don't like it
don't eat it but if you do then all i'm
saying
is that you don't necessarily need to be
buying processed fat-free cheese anymore
specifically in the name of health now
with all of that said
and i know it's confusing what are some
actual
evidence-based ways to reduce your risk
of heart disease through diet
number one choose whole grains over
refined grains
one meta-analysis found that eating just
three or more servings of whole grains
daily
was associated with 22 reduced risk of
heart disease
so you want to be sure to look for the
term whole grain on the ingredient list
as this means that the entire grain is
intact
number two eat more berries berries are
chock full of heart-healthy polyphenols
vitamin c and fiber so it's no surprise
that
numerous studies have demonstrated the
power of berries for heart health
not only are they a powerful antioxidant
but
they also have been found to
significantly lower ldl cholesterol
and blood pressure number three add in
some dark leafy greens
dark leafy greens like spinach kale
collard greens and mustard greens
are not only high in fiber but they're
also rich in vitamin k
which helps to protect our arteries one
meta-analysis
even found that increasing one's intake
of dark leafy greens
was associated with a sixteen percent
lower risk of heart disease
number four increase your omega-3s
omega-3 fats are important for helping
to reduce inflammation
and in turn protect our heart research
suggests that regularly eating salmon
which is one of nature's most potent
sources of omega-3s
for just eight weeks actually
significantly reduced blood pressure
when choosing fish i recommend looking
for ones that are higher in omega-3s
like salmon trout mackerel or sardines
and serving them baked broiled or
grilled without a batter or deep frying
delicious plant-based sources can
include things like chia seeds
walnuts flax seeds and hemp hearts
number five eat more
high fiber beans and legumes beans and
other pulses are not only
great plant-based proteins but they're
rich in resistant starch and fiber
which research suggests may help to
reduce bad ldl cholesterol
so throw a handful of chickpeas into
your salad your white beans in your soup
black beans and your tacos and lentils
in your curry for some heart healthy
and of course money conscious meals
number six eat more plant-based fats
like nuts
seeds and avocado as a fantastic source
of monounsaturated fats and fiber
nut seeds and avocado can be your heart
healthy bffs
some nuts and seeds like walnuts flax or
hemp hearts
even have those plant-based omega-3s we
were just talking about
so research has found that eating nuts
reduced the risk of heart disease
while another study found that those who
ate avocados regularly
were half as likely to develop metabolic
syndrome
number seven eat the rainbow when it
comes to eating vegetables and fruit
color is king there are a number of
important antioxidants that can be
derived from
brightly colored veggies so lycopene and
tomatoes for example which i know is a
fruit
has been linked to a reduced risk of
heart disease and stroke
while alpha and beta-carotene in orange
carrots or yellow beets
have been shown to lower the risk of
death from heart disease
there are so many delicious ways to get
your colorful veggie fix
from peppers to squash to pumpkins and
beets
so choose a favorite and get cooking
number eight is to swap some of your
meat for soy protein to make some more
meatless
meals soy protein found in tofu tempeh
edamame and soy milk
is packed with soy isoflavones which
research suggests
may help to reduce total cholesterol and
bad ldl cholesterol
try switching your cream for soy in your
coffee throwing some tofu into your stir
fry
or adding edamame to your salads or
soups number nine
choose more monounsaturated oils like
olive oil more often
as i discussed in my oil video here we
do know that extra virgin olive oil
contains those really healthy
monounsaturated fats that we want to
include in abundance
one study found that those who consumed
the most olive oil for example
were 35 percent less likely to develop
heart disease
that's impressive number 10 drink more
green tea
not only is matcha super trendy right
now but it's rich in polyphenols and
catechin antioxidants
which research suggests may help to
lower ldl cholesterol and total
cholesterol so if you're not
into replacing your morning joe with tea
you can also mix matcha powder into
oatmeals
smoothies or desserts bottom line
does saturated fat cause heart disease
well while we
still don't know for certain to what
extent saturated fat is harmful to our
health
i strongly believe that we need to stop
vilifying
any one particular food or food
component
and this includes saturated fat while
the research remains controversial
and i ultimately do believe we should
err on the side of caution
i also think that the focus should be
less on completely cutting saturated fat
out
and more on what we can add to our diet
to
add value saturated fat may or may not
be bad but the general consensus from
the body of
contradictory evidence suggests that
it's probably
not that beneficial either the research
is clear that unsaturated fats and
fiber-rich carbohydrates
may be more beneficial so let's try to
focus on adding
more of those foods in that means
there's still room for ice cream
and butter and coconut milk but the
priority should be
on nuts seeds avocado and olive oil
whenever possible
i believe that when we eat a diet full
of variety
we're providing our body with the
important nutrients that it needs
while also satisfying our desire for
delicious
and diverse food so aim for balance
but also remember that life is too short
to completely eliminate foods that you
actually love
and on that note if you like this video
please be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with any big
nutrition questions that you'd like me
to tackle
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you